it's a funny thing you know you get
given the responsibility to tell
somebody's
story if it's true you've got to bust
your balls for it
you've got to go the extra mile this is
somebody else's life you know
and i feel that responsibility very
heavily it's funny that you're making me
very nostalgic just even talking about
this sort of stuff obviously part of the
process
prompt stomper you know i read the
script i found it very very difficult
subject matter to deal with having grown
up through the punk era you know i'd
seen
guys who were punks because of their
their music preference or because of
making a stand against
corporate rock i'd seen some of those
guys morph
into neo-nazis i think i did probably
five or six
physical auditions for that before i was
cast in the role
very short shoot maybe 28 days so super
intense you have to get into character
very quickly you're working with a group
of young guys and
everybody's a bit afraid of it you know
jackie mckenzie was the principal female
lead
she didn't know what she was getting
into either you know she'd come just out
of
film school but it was the quality of
the idea that you could attack such a
heavy
subject matter that was just so
compelling and so attractive
what the [ __ ] are you afraid of
this is our place no more running
we stop them here
you know it ended up being quite an
incredible calling card for me it went
definitely went ahead of me and did its
own work
sometimes to my detriment though i
probably had
at least a dozen conversations with
directors in los angeles
who had somehow been told the story that
i was in fact
a skinhead who had been discovered on
the streets
dragged into the film world but that
wasn't
that wasn't the case at all the next
choice that i made
in terms of a commercial movie was to
play
a gay rugby playing plumber in a movie
called the some of us
i just always liked the idea that
somebody who was into romper stomper for
the wrong reasons
saw that i was in another film bought a
ticket
and now they're sitting in front of some
of us wondering how the [ __ ] they got
there
la confidential my process then
was not to do smaller roles i was
already doing roles where my name was
above the title so i tried to stay in
that pocket
i got the call from curtis hanson he was
really happy
to find out that i had in fact done
american movies already
which would give him potentially an
easier point of
argument to the studio because his idea
was
to cast relative unknowns you know he
sent me the script and i read the james
elroy book
la confidential and the thing that
freaked me out was bob white is
described as physically the biggest man
in the los angeles police department
i kind of got back on the phone with
curtis we hadn't met yet
i said man i don't know what impression
you might have got from the movies that
you've seen but you know i'm not really
like a big bloke mate you know
his vibe on that was that everything
that he required
and bud white he'd seen in other work
and
that was immaterial to him merry
christmas
merry christmas to you officer
that obvious huh it's practically
stamped on your
forehead it was a weird situation
because the big overarching studio in
this studio directly
making the movie um didn't like curtis's
idea so i was flown in and i was put up
at a hotel
in the time we were supposed to be
rehearsing but you know i've got you
know friends in the business and stuff
and people would be telling me
that sean penn was going to be playing
my role you know i was talking to the
director and
that was my character to play but at one
point in time
they stopped paying my hotel bill
um and rental car bill stopped providing
me with pedium and i really didn't have
you know a lot in my life at the time so
i wasn't able to pay
for that level of hotel etc and so it
got pretty heavy and
to the point where you know there was a
few times there where i was going down
the back stairs
so the hotel manager wouldn't stop me in
the foyer and ask me
what was going on i could feel all of
that stuff around me
and the only thing i had to go on was
the surety of the director that he'd
made his choice
so i just went with that and i just kept
turning up to work
i think if there was ever a day where i
got frustrated by it
and i hadn't turned up to work that
would have been the [ __ ] in the armor
that they
would have used to shift me out of the
role
you know and the same process happened
with with guy with guy pierce
why don't you go after criminals for a
change instead of cops stensland got
what he deserved and so will you
curtis asked me about guy he was a
regular character on a soap opera called
neighbours
that i dropped in on and did like a
small character for two or three days
i had a girlfriend i eventually ended up
marrying some many many years later
and i'm a very jealous person and we
walked into this pub
and a guy was there and he greeted her
effusively and
gave her a cuddle and a kiss and i'm
sort of standing there
he hasn't even acknowledged my existence
at this point in time
so i waited till there was a lull in
their conversation and i stepped forward
and i gave him a kiss
and i behaved effusively like he was
doing
with danielle because why can't i join
in
and he didn't do anything he
acknowledged with his eyes
sorry mate that was a bit dicky of me to
cut you out of the conversation
and later on when i was talking to
curtis and i told him that story
and i told him how completely
cool under fire guy pierce had been
and i think that really fell into
the part of guy that curtis had thought
he'd seen in the auditions
and so that's how we became that team in
that movie
[Music]
the insider you know at the time
definitely the most difficult job
i've done i got contact by michael mann
you know and and he
asked me to fly down to los angeles and
talk to him and he sent me the script
and i read it
and i couldn't work out what character
that he wanted me to play because it was
a script full of middle-aged men
i rang him first and said i don't i
don't get what character and he said the
guy man the lead guy you know
and i was like yeah that guy's he's 50
something i'm 30 something michael said
look just come and see me come talk to
me you know we had a
very very long conversation without any
fences and we talked about this and that
to do with society and corporate
malfeasance and blah blah blah
and it was a great chat you know and i
said to him
look i uh i don't get
why you want me to play this character
i'm just i'm not the age
i don't look anything like him michael
sort of came around from behind his desk
and he said listen
man i didn't uh fly down here because
of what he looked like and he put his
hand on my chest he said i flew you down
to meet you because of what you have in
here
and pushing that you know and it was
like in that moment i was like i'm going
to work with this guy
i'm going to do anything he wants i'm
going to climb any mountain
so he really worked out who i was
because he freaking got a hook in me
very deeply you know
jeffrey is you know a nice fella but
he's kind of an uncomfortable fellow and
he'd had
a very strange journey you know where he
begins in the bronx and ends up
sort of working in japan and and doing
all these things that
that gave his voice such a crazy
colorful array because you know now he's
working in the tobacco industry for
example
and he's working in kentucky so
as a scientist he's never used words
connected to the tobacco industry so
when he says those words
they have a pronounced southern lilt but
a lot of the
time he has that bronx
base but the bronx base is also
infused with the fact that he spoke
japanese for a number of years in his
life so
i'm looking at it going what the [ __ ] do
i do with this
you know it was a bit of a mind-blowing
experience
so what you're saying is it isn't enough
that you fired me for no good reason
now you question my integrity on top of
the humiliation
of being fired you threatened me you
threatened my family
it never crossed my mind not to honor my
agreement
i will tell you mr sanderfer and brown
and williamson too [ __ ] me
well [ __ ] you michael is such a
perfectionist and he wants to really
know what he has and what he's going for
and stuff so you know one example
my very young hair would just not sit
like jeffrey weigan's old hair
so we bleached it um
the color came back we bleached it again
color came back i think we ended up
bleaching it seven times
in a period of three weeks and then we
started to shave the volume out of it
you know my
young hair would just go and it would be
there the next day if we were going to
do it that way we would have to be
shaving
my head in those areas every morning and
and still
no matter how much volume we cut out of
my hair no matter how many
undercuts and everything that we did one
or two days later
it would go and it would find a way
to cover my head so we were standing
doing a screen test
and i was so pleased to find out that
dante spanotti who i'd met first on the
quick and the dead
director of photography uh was on the
insider as well because you know i had a
great relationship with his camera crew
guys and
and i was really excited to know that
that it was him and i was standing there
and
possibly a little offensive you know i
said you know this is not working with
the hair man
you know i've got to get a wig i've got
to have like really [ __ ] hair i've got
to have hair like his
and pointed at dawn too and dante's got
lovely hair but it was just it was of
this the right age
you know and it was behaving in the way
that jeffrey's hair
behaved you know so we got an incredible
wig maker with the wig it just made me
feel like the character you know and
that was
like a bit it was quite a big thing for
me because even when i'm doing the
insider i'm still really formulating
who i am as a film actor it's probably
my what
16th or 17th movie by then that really
showed me that because
of the visual nature of film if somebody
says
you're going to play a pirate you know
get an eye patch
you know rent a parrot you might
immediately feel more connected
to the character of a pirate if you do
so i did not
feel i could play that role until i
looked in the mirror
and it looked like jeffrey now other
times i've done characters where i feel
i don't necessarily need to be
accurate but because his story was so
real because it had such a deep
psychological effect on him
and his family and because it was such
an important step
in the legal and cultural life of
america
i just felt this need to honor him and
be very
careful about honoring him so you know i
met a whole bunch of
fantastic actors in that job you know to
be surrounded by people like al pacino
and christopher plummer somebody from
the film company at the time rang me to
tell me that
they were going to mount an academy
award campaign on my behalf
and i said oh cool you know so that's
like me and al that's fantastic and they
said no well
we're going to put our emphasis on you
and we asked
mr pacino and he said back the kid
it's a massive thing for him to have
done did you mention my name you haven't
talked to anybody about that
why are brown williams and no i suppose
how do i know about brother happened
just after i talked
like coincidence well i don't like
paranoid accusation
time came up later in my career
it was the movie cinderella man paul
giamatti's mum
died during the course of shooting a
cinderella man and i made her a promise
on the phone
that paul was such an incredible actor
that he would be nominated and the
studio asked me what i wanted to do
and i said back the kid and paul
giamatti got an academy award nomination
so the insider is very very important
for my growth
as um an actor
and uh also
extremely important for the way my
career went
uh just after that
cinderella man i'd worked with ron
howard on a beautiful mind
and i gave him the script and he said
you know look
i understand why you want to do it he
said but i don't understand why i would
want to direct it it's like
ground so many people have covered you
know i said to him well it's just like
a beautiful mind man the importance of
this story
is that it's true this guy this what
happened to him
you know he was a boxer successful he
owned a cab company
well if you own that cab company in
manhattan and
wall street crashes in 1929 and people
can't afford to take cabs
it's possibly the only time in history
that owning a cab company in manhattan
has been
a negative thing but so you know jim
from
going through his sporting career and
rising to a certain
middle-class position sank and slid all
the way
back to the bottom again and then out of
pure desperation
rose and became a champion and i just
i'd fallen in love with that story when
i first read it
and it was super important to me and
i think i was very passionate with ron
describing why it was important
so he came on board and you know it's
just one of the nature of the film if he
hadn't have come
on board i probably don't make that film
in the cycle of things if we had to
start from scratch
and find another director it probably
reshapes you know i had a
run of bad luck
and uh this time around i know what i'm
fighting for
oh yeah what's that jimmy
milk you know through the course of the
process of that it was
like a physically extremely tough role
i've actually done
more difficult physical roles since
but at that time the preparation for
that film and
you know if i could show you a list of
what we
were doing on a daily basis it was heavy
stuff and and you know ron is very
serious director
and he brought angelo dundee who trained
15 world champions into my life
and angelo constructed the energy
in the training camp and you know i mean
sometimes you just
just get so lucky having angelo dundee
with all of his
wisdoms and experiences come into my
life as a mentor and you know
i only knew him alive for eight years
but what a joyful person he was what an
inspirational person you know
occasionally i would sort of just say
i don't know how i'm gonna do this he
just had a way
of making you believe so it required an
immense amount of discipline
to play that character you know i was so
into that world
so into that place when i made the
decision that because i'm playing a
boxer at a certain point in time
i would have a prosthetic nose and a
certain point in time i would have
cauliflowered prosthetic ears also
because of the black and white
photographs i'd seen a jim braddock
he had very kind of wingnut ears you
know poking out from the side of the
head
so we had these pieces made which
pushed my ears out like that and um
whoa it came to see me and he's like you
know
russell uh as a guy who grew up
with ears like that i'm just wondering
if we need to make that
that kind of decision do we need to be
that accurate i kind of saw what their
problem was later on when
they sort of were trying to market the
movie every image
you know even if it was a romantic image
and they were focusing on the love story
between
uh my character and renee's character i
got the nose
i got the ears gladiator
um after i'd finished the insider ridley
and michael
had a conversation i went to meet ridley
i looked like absolute [ __ ] i don't
see how he could possibly have seen me
as a roman general but we really got on
he had gigantic ideas and i kind of
thought most of them were impossible
really
um and it certainly wasn't on the page
there was no
script that we could be enthused about
but what i was enthused about was the
simple idea it's 184 idea or 180 ad
you're a roman general and you're being
directed by ridley scott
you know so that drove my motivation a
lot you know it was very difficult
putting on those clothes and going oh
yeah [ __ ]
off we go i'm a roman general and i know
that joaquin phoenix
had the same problem because we talked
about it you know the heights that those
characters had to go to
you know it was and it's very different
because at that stage
you know if you're wearing clothes like
that you're probably doing a comedy
or a piss take you know sword and sandal
things had been
out of vogue for you know a long time
that
whole idea was constructed
around the sincerity of the core journey
of a man's vengeance for the death of
his wife and child
my name is maximus desmos meridius
commander of the armies of the north
general of the felix legions loyal
servant to the true emperor
marcus aurelius father to a murdered son
husband to a murdered wife and i will
have my venues
in this life or the next it's funny
though you see the backstage
or behind the scenes footage and
everybody's just goofing around and
being
silly and you know the reason you do
that is you're saving all your serious
[ __ ]
for after the guy says action you know
most people
the complexities of film are such that
you have to have everything organized to
the nth degree
your scheduling you know your purchasing
your crewing
all of these things have to be worked
out and particularly with your art
department
and you know you set dresses and
everything so everybody knows what
they're doing
that's the way you make a film however
we were making a movie that grew as we
made the movie
and little things became big ideas
and we were being fluid within that
gigantic
100 plus million dollar budget shape
which is all about schedules and
disciplines
and being exact about things even down
to you know this one conversation
um i had with ridley where i said i
wanted to
decapitate a guy you know and at the end
of this fight sequence and he said well
look you know i can't just add
uh a decapitation um it's a pretty heavy
thing i'm going to have to discuss it
with the studio and everything and i
said look this is the way the
choreography goes at the moment and i
showed him i said this is what i want to
change it to and i showed him
and he could see that it was more
dynamic and more
part of the character and the last move
of that sequence was
this decapitation you know and he's
literally smoking a cigar
he said what i've had to say he's
watched it you know a couple of puffs on
a cigar
and he calls out to his first assistant
director and he goes
terry how many heads have we got left
you know
but working with ridley i always liken
it to
working with some great renaissance
painter just the way he sees the world
and that the level of artistry
he converts onto the screen you know
i've ended up making five movies with
ridley
and every single one of those
experiences
you know has got to be in my top 10 of
films that i've made robin hood
actually my first step on robin hood
when the idea came up
was grab every robin hood book that i
could big bag of them and i got on a
boat
in northern queensland and just started
to read so i just wanted to know what
the mythology was
as much of what i could find out and
what it occurred to me and what i
brought up with ridley was that we all
have a reshaped view of robin hood
which it comes from victorian times but
in fact
this legend started many many hundreds
of years before then we started
looking at the facts of the currently
understood myth
and the realities of the history
timeline
and always in stories of robin hood in a
modern era
king richard comes into the story he's
been away
on crusade and he comes into the story
at the end of the story to sort of save
the day you know confirm that robin is a
good man
and the sheriff of nottingham was
incorrect and blah blah but what we
discovered is that you know apart from a
few months earlier in his life
king richard was french he didn't make
it back to england he went on crusades
and he died in france that was our first
hook it's like okay everybody else is
expecting a robin hood
where king richard
comes in at the end to save the day our
robin hood begins
with the death of king richard who died
putting a castle to siege in france you
know and of course i got to work with
the magnificent cate blanchett or la
blanchett as i call her
on that film and found out that you know
not only is she a
wonderful actress she's spectacular
company as well
i'm ashamed of you hello marion
i've come to save you i remember
standing on that set in the bourne wood
the same place
we'd shot certain parts of gladiator and
i'm looking up the hill
at this french castle that the art
department have built on top of the hill
and i'm looking around me hundreds of
archers and we have 180 horses
galloping down the beach this is
probably the last
physical production of this scale that i
ever get to do
you know things were changing so rapidly
and it's it's proven to be that way now
sure i've been on
big budget films but not in that kind of
scale
where everything's built you know
[Music]
look the idea of this script was kind of
nauseating when i first read it
i really didn't think i i wanted to have
anything to do with it but then
you know somebody asked me actually why
why are you not going to do it you know
and it's like because it's really scary
and it scares me that this
is actually something that does happen
this individual this character is acting
on such a basis of
a lack of humanity a lack of empathy
and he is imploding and he's going to
take her with him
ma'am are you okay i'm pretty sure the
guy in that truck's following me
he's road raging why don't you just
chill man go your
way
[Music]
you know one of the things that was
really important to me with this is that
we don't at any stage
try to justify his actions or his
thought process
because most of us will go through this
sort of thing and be
you know it's just the ups and downs and
the foibles and quirks of life
but this particular man um
has uh decided that uh
all of this adds up to his
right to destroy and terrorize
and we've seen that kind of personality
at play i mean 20 years ago i would have
in my mind kind of written itself as
some kind of
anomaly you know but that's the thing
that kept playing on my mind when you
you know school shootings and shootings
and nightclubs but it is the same
thought process and therefore it became
more important to me and when i was
particularly based off my conversations
with derek
and his perspective as a filmmaker
i knew that this movie ends up not being
just about thrills and crashes and
violence this movie
ends up being a direct commentary
on the state of american society western
society today
so it went from being the thing i was
most scared of
to the thing i just felt most
responsible to have to do
so uh gq and those of you that have
tuned in
um that's the end of that i've been
boring your tits off for quite some time
now
talking about some of my iconic
characters
iconic being somebody else's definition
and i'm just
the putz who has to say it but anyway i
hope you got something out of it
enjoy yourself and thank you gq